.
> BEENL MOVEMENT YOUR ENTIRE LI.
WE IN CITYPEOPLEND
TNT FEEL TO
YOU? LITTLE BIT WHATE''70s REALY
THAT,E
SUCCEED, M TO THE NEXTCHAPIHOG
TIME.T THE MORE STUDIED HISTORY
T REALIZATION THATCOUNTRY, THI
WHHEEDLE ELECTED BARACK OBTHER
RI A
TREVTHTHE PUSHED
YOU,I FEEL
TOUT THIS
COUN IS AT GONE STREETS,
WH GO T CO OAIF WON'TND THE ENDH
DEMOCRACYT EVER OEA SKE
THAT HIGH,HA
ALTERNIV
ELD ONE OF THE  TO
UNT TO DO,OI F
I KT
O FAIL LEARN
THE LESSO E
BOUNDO REMION IS, WARNED ANY L
O BERNINGS.
'T, THE'R G REPEAT STUDIEDO MATY
WA SAYD --NE RESEARCHAN
E THOMASEFRS SAIDTHAT THE PIBLLA
WHETHER  N  IT IS
PCEER ISRNAL
VIGILA LHAT.
>> LASTN
THERE WAS A C RKFOR TH FIRST TE
BACK IN
SO I LOO
IT 1943D
REASONRE AUR WTE
RIERICAN N, SDIWH A I
DIDN'T KILL T HIM.
AND THAT L DAY
WHAT TY CURWHA
SO,N LOOKS A
AND OK,
BEEN PROTESTSNGND THE PROBLEMS
IL S D TO GIVE
>> WELL, I SAY EN THE
SYSTEM.
DO LIK US
DO A COUPLE L PEOPLE ALL THE I A
SO IHAT AWE STAYEDARRIED FOR 58.
I THINK THAT WE  ALWAYMEMBER TE
. TOGETHER,
ING SOLIDITITHOTHER AND DY'S
VIOLENCE INOUR
THEREGHT, THE UNJUS USEFORCE.
IT ASHE
HE PRESIDENT
UNJUSTLY, AN PIN THE STREETS ARN
R LAWRD
PRESIDENT.
O MEMSEFULPROTESTERS,ELING SYST
EQL WHOALLING
R TREATMENT UNDER THEE WHOAN AN
FORCELAW AND ORD IS POLICEORCENR
Y , WIL UST
WTTREPUAN INEN C
N  THIS IT T' PLEDGE
EDF
UNITED STATEEN BBLICANE
MITCH MAN TTWAATTE,ING THINGS,H.
WE'VE GOT TO
JUDIAL
WE OUR
SYEM AWAY FROMMO STOPCAUSEEOPLE
WHEN I CLENV I
CAME
W 10, 2FOA.
ISWHERTHE POPAT  BE YEEE BY
DOT SOMEEODREPARATIS. M AND
JUST L
PEOPLE ARE TRYING THAT THIS MOCE
HE INSULTS ANLTE. THIS
HO WOU REPUBCA WUP
COUNTRLLO
T
OIT
WEIGHED IN ON THESIDENT'S
THRE T S ACTIVE DUTY
TROO INTCAN STA IN  ON DOMATTHEK
TITELLMULLEN, FORME CEFSF
STNDERS BUSH
HE ES OURELLOWENHE MUST NEVER
BECOHE I OF
THE CARNAGEARWITN ENDEAVORRICANT
IGOR NOT